bonjour carlo alberto brusa merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france on connaît la lenteur de la
justice italienne et les possibilités de
recours
matteo salvini et risque est il
réellement une peine de prison
pour le moment le problème de la prison
ne se pose pas ce qui compte pour le
moment et la vie politique ce que solvin
il peut encore vous présenter pour
l'italie après ce renvoi en
correctionnelle certes la condamnation à
l'italie pour arriver dans quelques
années mais aujourd'hui le fait que le
sénat et l'aider d'immunité
parlementaire place sa vie dans une
position de quelqu'un qui est
aujourd'hui je dirais utilisons terme
français mis en examen soupçonnés
d'avoir commis une infraction pénale
en sa qualité de ministre avec le risque
d'une peine plus lourde
donc c'est une tache sur le chemin que
lui l'avait préconisé pour devenir
premier ministre qui ne fait que
accroître l'erreur commise jeudi c'est à
dire la promeneuse démission pour tenter
de renverser la vapeur pendant 2 le
pouvoir avec des nouvelles élections
mais ce chemin que il avait construit da
pas abouti 1 quelle est la réaction de
l'opinion publique en italie sk matteo
salvini un resto populaire malgré cette
décision du sénat il reste au populaire
il ya eu quand même une baisse c'est à
dire que le nouveau gouvernement formé
entre le parti démocratique de la gauche
et de mon 5 étoiles à rassurer un peu le
pays actuellement il ya une certaine
stabilité
les attaques de sa vie ni contre son
gouvernement
ses prises de position et surtout
surtout utilisant le terme de défaite
un emile romain nadal lors des élections
régionales ont fait baisser sa
popularité
donc aujourd'hui il n'est plus supportée
par une opinion publique majoritaire
même si la ligue du nord reste le parti
majoritaire le dernier sondage donne le
parti à 37 38 % il n'en demeure pas
moins que aujourd'hui il ya une
désaffection parce que cette arrogance
cette manière de faire de la politique
été critiqué et surtout l'apparition du
mouvement des sardines a naturellement
je dirais ça paie cette tentative de sa
vie ni deux je dirais placé la lutte
entre deux extrêmes
l'italie a besoin de sérénité a besoin
de recentrage et cette position
d'extrême droite sont aujourd'hui
insupportable
derrière cette décision du sénat ce qui
pourrait y avoir des retournements
d'alliances politiques à les capturer le
nom la positon renvoi en correctionnelle
utilisant ce terme à la française de
monsieur sévigny est un pas de plus pour
que ce gouvernement se renforce et que
salvini soit placé sur les marges ou
sous le pont aux le port de la politique
italienne
aujourd'hui il ya eu des tentatives la
situation et des beaucoup plus compliqué
au niveau du gouvernement du côté des
dorine c est notamment sur le problème
de la prescription pénale ou
effectivement des conflits internes
existent au niveau du parti démocratique
de la gauche notamment entre son
président y y et réussie qui a créé
cette sorte de parti qui joue un peu le
chantage mais sa vie n'est pas une
menace actuellement au l'italie bien au
contraire il s'est marginalisée et de
plus en plus il sera marginalisé par
tous ces tentatives de recentrage qui
demandait aussi pas l'europe
qu'est ce qui va se passer selon vous
d'ici les prochaines échéances
électorales
je l'avais déjà dit sur votre plateau il
y a une volonté de maintenir ce
gouvernement parce que le maintien de
son gouvernement
marginalisée de plus en plus donc les
prochaines élections elles ne sont pas
derrière la porte au pied le contraire
je pense que ce gouvernement va tenir
tout sera fait le parti démocratique de
la gauche à travers ce gouvernement a la
possibilité de répondre à main la
politique italienne de se redresser
après des échecs que rainsy avait causé
donc quand on a un gouvernement on
arrive à tenir et dans un contexte
difficile parce que des problématiques
avec la chine d'économie les difficultés
aujourd'hui que toute l'europe va
connaître à la suite aux 6 2
puis demi de la pandémie ce sont des
situations qui nécessitent une grande
stabilité politique et l'europe réclame
que à l'italie cette stabilité sont
maintenus parce qu'après le vrai site il
faut vraiment qu'il y ait une unité de
tous les pays d'europe et éviter ainsi
des marginalisations extrêmement
dangereuse pour le lycée de l'europe et
surtout pour la bataille économique que
les prochains mois où on dirait devront
affronter tous les grands dirigeants de
l'europe c'est le mot de la fin merci
qu'à me carlo alberto brusa d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris et spécialiste de la politique
italienne